Robert how will you fund all these
projects for crowd-sourced studios yeah
that's one of the reasons it's we're
called crowdsource to do is once we have
the principal elements the director of
the script the actors then we go to a
crowdfunding site and we raise the
production budget for the film and if
we're successfully funded then we go
make the movie well you have a team of
people trying to be part of the
crowdfunding campaign or how will that
work sure yes so our members the members
of our the people who are voting for the
scripts and so forth those are our
members and all you have to do to be a
member is to give us your email address
that's it and if you feel like it vote
for you no script or actors or all three
or whatever it is and hopefully those
same people who voted for the script and
the actors in the director will join us
and say yeah you know what I helped to
pick the actor or the script I'll give
10 bucks to get a digital copy of the
film and they'll help yeah and yeah you
know the end game for us is those same
members who helped pick the actors in
the script and so forth and presumably
or hopefully help us produce a film
raise the budget will be the end users
they'll be the audience for it so do you
plan on directing any of these films
just to be on the safe side there are a
lot of sort of question marks as you
know we want we have some sort of
control issues which is a good point
because but the short answer is yeah
they're just the first one I'm going to
direct and somebody raised the issue
what happens if we hire a nightmare
director or we hire so we're going to
have to you know consider that when
we're picking finalists like do we want
to work with this person and there's
always a wild card with an actor or
whatever it is so we are going by the
sort of Miss America policy which is for
whatever reason we have the right to get
rid of an actor or director whatever it
is probably not a screenplay writer but
it's unlikely that they'll become a
nightmare once we choose the script but
the runner-up whoever got the second
most
will replace them under you know if we
if we encounter that sort of a
circumstance yeah what if you want to
change a screenplay how much leeway do
you feel cuz you know I know a lot of
screenwriters are very precious about
their work oh you mean if we want it oh
just a little bit yeah yeah yeah just
within get used to it yeah okay that's
like that's part of the deal that's part
of the contract too so yeah I mean I've
had that experience as a writer and it's
painful and stuff but you're gonna have
to assume that if we're making this
movie it's hopefully in good hands and
you're happy with it but yeah we
absolutely reserve the right to you know
I don't anticipate a major rewrite
hopefully the it's sort of like when
you're making a movie the casting is
ninety percent of it so when we choose
these finalists we're going to you know
we're going to assume that they're not
necessarily camera-ready but they're
pretty damn close but yeah we may we may
do some rewrites right so people can go
to crowdsource studios com and they can
go on there and it can submit their work
first just screenplays right now it
sounds like that's all you're taking
correct yeah until we have this we can't
really figure out a director and
certainly not actors until we have the
script right okay yep okay and then any
tips to these screenwriters on how they
should present themselves when they
pitch because you know some lot of
screenwriters or not they don't feel may
be comfortable in front of the cameras
so how should they kind of make
themselves feel a little bit more
approachable in selling their story you
know I just think be passionate about it
like you know it can be at the end of
the day it's just you know we'll decide
it's not so much about presentation
although you know you know if your
dynamic and stuff it it helps but you
need to have a solid story so if you're
really amped about a story that's like
yeah I don't really care you're not
going to win probably but I just think
if the beauty to of doing something like
this just like with actors now most
actors audition on camera I mean on
video they send it around don't actually
go and show up so you can do with 500
times until you get it right you know
you're the only one so wait till you get
it right and
be passionate about it and it's a you
know it's like a beauty contest in a way
you know what I mean it's like you kind
of the most it's got to be a little bit
of definitely 5050 style and substance
I'd say because again you can have the
greatest pitch and have a shitty script
and it's you'll lose and vice versa if
it's all style and no substance you're
not going to win either right any tips
for writers who were a little more self
effacing sometimes that works in your
favor if you're Jerry Seinfeld and
sometimes it just comes off as just stop
you know have a little more confidence
in yourself that might work for some
people some people like that you never
know so just sort of be yourself i guess
and if you're really excited i can't
imagine anybody who's pitching their own
script isn't really excited about it so
just figure it out take your time i mean
you you're uploading a video it's not
live theatre or anything so yeah
you